so we've been given a new look at doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness in
the form of some new images footage and
an interview which sam remy has done so
let's get straight into it the first
image is of doctor strange chavez and
one which it looks like they're in the
sanctum of sanctorum they're all looking
at something together chavez looks to be
a bit confused and worried where wang
has a serious phrase and lastly doctor
strange has a serious face as well but
also looks like he is questioning what
he has seen possibly they're all looking
at a variant of someone or maybe it's
something completely different it's
really hard to tell what they're looking
at i would say this is straight after
the battle of gangang toss in the street
then after that battle they've all gone
into the sanctuary sanctorum next up we
have a shot of doctor strange mordo and
doctor change again as a zombie so the
first show of doctor strange here is of
him at the temple they're looking at
something in the distance now what i
think is happening is they're all
looking at the mysterious person which
we have seen in previous trailers and tv
spots now i believe this mysterious
person is actually wonder herself
because we can splice together some
clips and it looks like she is the one
who is attacking them moving on we have
mordo pulling out his sword before he
attacks doctor strange this is just a
new shot of the same sequence that we
have seen before and this is also the
same case with the zombie doctor strain
but it's still cool nevertheless to see
more footage of this zombie doctor
strange now let's get into the interview
information so this interview was done
by eric davis where he interviewed sam
remy so let's break it down so in terms
of setting multiverse of madness picks
up roughly a few months after spider-man
no way home this is the first time that
characters from our universe who go out
into the multiverse and experience other
universes so this is really exciting to
hear it seems like the title multiverse
of madness is actually what we'll be
getting our characters will be traveling
to different universes and experiencing
the multiverse at first hand opposed to
no way home where they came from
different universe into the main
universe and this one will be traveling
out to other universes as well which is
exciting to hear so who exactly is the
villain of doctor change the multiverse
of madness is it strange wonder mordo
the multiverse all of it above sam remy
says i'm not really meant to answer this
question but i would say at different
times all of the above so it seems like
there's not a set villain unless if sam
remy's trying to hide who the set
villain is but from this quote at least
it sounds like there'll be multiple
villains now you might be wondering how
is strange going to be a villain well i
would say this is actually a variance of
him possibly zombie doctor strange or
who i think the main strange villain
will be is sinister strange which we
have seen more in depth in the previous
tv spot where he has a third eye and you
can even see strange himself going to
attack him it's not just doctor strange
who will see multiple versions of it's
one to two why is her accent back well
that isn't the one that we know so that
wonder we saw in a previous trailer was
just talking about the nightmares she
has had apparently this isn't the one
that we know so is this referring to a
different variant of wonder that goes on
the rampage was this referring to the
same wonder but she's being corrupted by
the darkhold let me know what you guys
think in the comment section below and
with that that's pretty much everything
about this video so let me know what you
guys think in the comment section below
and if you haven't already please like
and subscribe and turn notifications on
to show your support thanks for watching